kaley cuoco and boyfriend Carl cook
competes the equestrian couple competed
separately at the low gene masters of
Los Angeles on Friday in Long Beach
here's Kaylee known as ke Christine on
horseback gyms adjacent like it wasn't
that Kate Christine and here's her
boyfriend Carl cook on Thursday the two
traded their horseback riding attire for
something a bit more elegant as they
made their red carpet debut it's very
exciting this means a lot to us Carl in
a light blue three-piece suit and Kaylee
and a bright printed dress with bold
cheetah print sleeves this is
unbelievable the adorable couple who
started heating up in March haven't been
shy about showing off their love on
social media they post tons of sweet PDA
photos together Plus Kaylee recently
opened up to CBS this morning about
their special connection I've actually
never been happier so I feel why are you
happy right now
what is it approaches I think that the
horse connection is is special yeah yeah
it's very he's about shared interest
yeah I love
you